the other people in the world of
criminals across guy grabs encompass
okay it's on hi everyone I'd like to
thank the organizers for the invitation
it's wonderful to be here and i'll be
talking about two joints papers one with
you Val Paris and the other with Alex
and with Olli and the work on involved
is on graph the walk with Alex and
always is on digraphs and complexes I
was kind of hoping that Alex would they
cover the necessary background and that
by this point everyone will already know
what building is but what we do is I
guess we'll try to please use a
substantial portion of the talking order
to explain what we believe is happening
and then i'll try to give ideas of that
will start with with the picture in in
dimension 14 graph and then we'll we'll
discuss the extensions okay so unlike
other talks I'm going to start with the
open problem and and these really are
open they are motivation they are maybe
you can look at them as the motivation
for the study but we still do not know
how to solve them we know the answer we
just can't prove it I think here is the
Kayla graph from avi stock right I hope
I didn't mess it up this is the right
one right it's one of the examples that
he gave in his talk so this is an
expander it's not a little gem graph but
it is an expander the regular photograph
and here is a basic question what can
you say about the profile of distances
so take two random points in so so all
look at the end and tell me what that
between them is they or what is the
average distance in this crap what
you really use the pipe yes kill the
time okay so this is the question number
one question number two seems kind of
unrelated but actually it's intimately
related and this is one of the themes
that will be repeated in this talk
understanding distances and the geometry
maximum distance is this typical
distances goes hand-in-hand with
understanding the behavior of various
types though the analogous type the
corresponding types of random walks on
your geometry so you're running a simple
random walk on on this graph and under
graph its okay its relics transitivity
and the skinny graph so it will converge
in particular its regulars will converge
to the uniform distribution and the
question is how long will it take it to
converge to the two equilibrium this is
question number one here the second
question is a little more delicate and
and it's not how long it takes you to
converge but how do you converge so it
is the case that you slowly approach
your equilibrium measure or is it the
case that for a long time you seem like
you're stuck in getting nowhere and then
the shell transition and all of a sudden
you are essentially at equilibrium
that's exactly what I mean because this
would be abrupt the cut-offs and gradual
would be no cut off okay so this was
question number one what yes constants
times log in I don't know what the
constant is and abrupt transition so for
a long time it will look like you are at
distance you will be a distance 1 minus
widow of one in total variation for
Makka Librium and then at that constant
times log n you will drop to distance 0
little depend on the hypercube yeah
that's that's what happens there
it's no soap okay so coupon collecting
gives you a an n log N and actually the
cutoff is it has that because you can
miss sqrt and you don't the stationary
distribution will not see the the normal
fluctuations of the last sqrt that you
miss but but but yeah all the diamonds
yeah almost all yeah okay so so this is
a this is what's supposed to happen here
we can show it we cannot show it but
it's kind of obvious that this has to be
the case with such a nice graph ok this
is question number one question number
two let's consider a 3 uniform
hypergraph so they would ask for an
explicit example ok don't know this
isn't going to work and I there is a
graph on a tee what is it 80 so eight
hundred and ten million vertices ok
let's say let's say the same that you
can there's a question about whether you
want to see are really an explicit
construction foreman ujan complexes or
just for for two-dimensional expanders
it always has an example for that we can
plot out but they're essentially and it
will be a relatively compact description
it will look something like this only
there would be many more make matrices
like that and it will it will be a ceili
graph and now the higher dimensional the
two-dimensional expander will just be
the cliq complex over that graph will
just look at whenever you have a
triangle and that would be your your
hike village so it will be priced with
three uniformed hypergraph with bounded
agree and that would be an expense now
what is lemon nude resolve all of the
required definition but take such a
thing okay and in this case I
the filling hill to the paper by boo
boskie best families and movie business
for mayor from 05 and now do the same
okay now you have a hypergraph and you
can still ask about distances so you
have triangles in the type of graph and
you can for instance this doesn't work
you can you can draw triangles like this
and and ask how many triangles you need
to glue the smallest number of triangles
that you need to glue to get from one
vertex to another if they are chosen
randomly that's a natural question you
can also maybe glue them like that okay
either overlapping all of this joint or
edge disjoint like clue so tight you can
ask all these questions this is smallest
distance in the cross Frank Torre you
even fix it it will be in this short
track yes yes I can't answer these
questions yet for this but we'll be able
to say some something long visa so these
are the these are still open any
question on the question
okay so and so this picture of the took
seemingly unrelated about shuffling
cards this has a similar nature you
essentially these all of these questions
revolves about the same thing we are
just applying we have some group in mind
and we're doing we're just applying some
we have a prescribed set of generators
we are applying them randomly and we're
asking how long it takes us to get
either from from one point to another
all to approach equilibrium and and this
this notion that Michael already
mentioned cut off means that we are this
al convergence to equilibrium looks like
essentially a step function okay so we
are at the maximal different and then we
drop to zero function are you measuring
like already we will get way too thanks
for the question okay so now let's start
being a little rigorous so the regular
expander this was already defined in
previous talks and and and so we're
Ramanujan graphs and what we'll what
what we'll want to discuss in this talk
they will always be the in this current
talk it will be the degree of regularity
of the graph and then I'll choose
something else for the dimension okay
and and if we look at this definition
will insist that Roman nose and graphs
are connected and I place it like this i
right i write this that lambda has
module either be so I'm allowing it to
be bipartite so plus or minus 0 0 in the
interval of minus two square udy minus 1
plus 2 squared D minus 1 here's a
picture of Ramanujan graphs this is the
the case of about 10,000 vertices fixed
regular this is psl to f 29 in the
original paper available if allah jalla
can you see that it's so the girls is
huge in these graphs and every so
everything is locally tree-like and then
once you you exceed beyond
beyond the the girls bound essentially
all hell breaks loose and we lose our
geometric understanding of what's going
on which is which poses a serious
problem for the analysis and and this is
a picture of the spectrum of two
different Ramanujan graphs one of them
so if the one with the spikes is the one
from the previous slide the multiplicity
of each eigenvalue is huge it's about a
it's about what is its Q which is n to
the 1 filled in this case so so
polynomial multiplicity for therefore
the eigenvalues and the nice flat one is
just a random list going back to nothing
day works many years ago okay so this is
a 1000 list of a of a of a small pitocin
graph just the Petersons graph so so
these look kind of different in the
limit the density will will will it will
still be kissin McKay but what we're
trying to understand really depends on
on the quantitative properties of these
eigenvalues so even though they look the
distribution structurally different the
behavior of these objects is we're
introducing in the opening slide it
should be the same and I want to just
mention a related previous related
recent development so always talk here
so they show the connection between some
illusion graphs and quantum computing
and so did the naturals talk and spend
so in both situations so we heard about
both the connection to quantum computing
and and the North the new understanding
of all the distances typical distances
and the maximal distance specifically in
a natural stock
okay so now we get back to your question
and I'm going to define this uh this
plot that I showed formerly what will be
interested in throughout will usually
swap this token and this is what we
typically are interested in is to
measure convergence to equilibrium via L
1 and the reason that we're interested
in l1 and you actually receive good
example of that in this talk is it l2
and essentially all the LPS fulfill out
over other one these are analytics
quantities that you can you can analyze
in various cases but they miss a lot of
the properties that you can extract from
knowing when the l1 cutoff really is
when one occurred so in this situation
we use the equivalence this equivalence
that tells you that the total variation
distance measures the worst
distinguishing statistic between the two
measures so this is a very very useful
poverty this is how we're going to
extract your metric consequences form
the knowledge of when of what the mixing
time is ok now follow a massive chain
with a certain transition a caramel p
and stationary distribution pipe we just
look at this total variation distance of
of the t-step probability measure
starting from X 2 pi and we wait for it
to drop below summit cyber so this is a
non increasing amount or non increasing
function by a by matt by eight let's say
by maximal coupling go away by enzymes
inequalities this will be true for any
LP at some point is going to drop below
trial on and we're going to declare that
that point is the mixing is T mix of a
child that means that you reach
equilibrium up to distance epsilon and
will be interested in the worst starting
point so maximum over all the initial
positions in our case actually most of
the most of the time there it may very
well be the case that the grass is
transitive but but in any case we take a
walk a starting position and we say this
cutoff occurs so this goes back to all
this and
a Coronation the early 80s so this is
the constantia shahani all those all
those iconic a sequence of chain exhibit
cut off essentially if epsilon doesn't
matter its OT mix it makes sense to say
what he makes is even if you have a
chain on 100 such as a finite chain this
notion already requires you to have a
sequence of chain in hand so there is
some underlying parameter end like the
number of cards or the number of
vertices in the graph and we want to say
that if you fix to precision parameters
epsilon epsilon prime and now you let
the size of your system run to infinity
then it won't really matter which one of
them you you chose the the two
quantities would be asymptotically the
same okay so point nine would be like
point one and that's exactly saying that
that this graph which now i can tell you
is just the total variation distance
south is one goes down to zero this
graph dropped abruptly so this little
this move from one to zero is captured
within the little
okay so so now we can revisit the first
example this this little caylee grass
and what can we say about it it is known
to be an expander okay I'll be all what
you mentioned it this is an expander and
the facet is an expander essentially
tells you that for any epsilon your
timox is sandwiched between two
constants times log in okay this first
constant is just because you have a
bounded degree so you have to before you
before some constant times log n you
just see a tiny in today a delta
fracture into the net ability so
certainly you are not close to alypium
this constant is a function of the
eigenvalue the spectral gap by
definition and by trigger's inequality
that we already held about there
yesterday you know that in l2 you will
at some constant times again you will
drop to two distances essentially zero
okay so certainly in l1 which is what
we're measuring so what we know is we
have these two constants and all the
action happens in this interval it's not
like it's not like you all your
convergences is going to extend
gradually to infinity like a random walk
on a cycle which is like normal I
properly cite Brownian motion so you you
can never really there is no single
point after which you are a distance
essentially zero this isn't the case
here you have a single point and you
know that after which you know you are a
distance essentially little over one and
the question is whether it looks like
that or whether there may be there are
multiple steps so maybe I don't know
what so this is what we don't understand
and and the intuition tells you that
maybe you could somehow concoct take
couple of different expanders and create
step functions which you can do actually
not so hard but the intuition tells you
that if the graph is transitive then you
you are not going to be able to do
anything and it's going to look just
single step function that is a distance
one and then drops the distance ago so
that's why we are convinced within the
opening slide these questions their
answers are what we think they are you
think for every transit is right yeah I
was yeah it's a conjecture will spill it
from over we'll get to that forever I
think any kind of diff expander any
family of transit is expanders this
would be the case led everyone honey you
grabs our creeks or Instagram soldiers
okay it's it's insanity so these are
ecstatic a Minnesota case like this
again what does the star wars in which
sort of several independent and want to
get to fix power of the mumble purposes
like n to the 49 than in one or two
slaps your youngster so this is this
requires very mild extension of function
when you ate ate at me to keep your
eager to encumber okay so let's hook so
you're okay so so let's focus on on on
three bullets are a from this slide
first is that until 2010 we had
essentially one example of cut off on
the bounded degree grass in this proof
this is lamplighter onesie and to
diffuse the estimates from the brief
from doing the same saw a lot of math
paper on the cuddle time of random walk
on v2 this use some very hard estimates
this work but you we need to compare
this with a conjecture of the way I was
floating around also we may in a
previous paper with a bitter sticky that
on almost every three regular graph you
should have cut off so the the default
is if you take a random the regular
graph it should have cut off but we
couldn't prove it on on essentially any
example for most okay
until last year we had no example of a
transitive expander with couples and
this is the conjecture that I was
telling Ric about the next pair is made
I looked before when I prefer the slide
to this talk I looked and I saw that
they around 2012 I was trying to push
for people to maybe look at this into
this congestion I gave maybe three
colloquial talks that year and in each
of them I wrote at there at the last
slide conjectural Paris on every
transitive ex showed it on every
transitive expander you have cut off and
then question is there any transitive
expander where you have cut off and i
would make the joke that usually when
you make a conjecture on the entire
family of grass it's after you saw one
two three examples including muster your
courage to say that it's like that fall
for the entire family and yet we had no
advance so this was the case until last
year no examples but still the
conjecture was that it's a for everyone
oh it's the book but of the way it's
actually it's a great random graph
dynamics ready to see if you are serious
okay this is where he made the contact
so here's a helo sum a sum some more
developments there was this wonderful
proof by Friedman of their of an August
conjecture that almost every deregulate
graph is weekly revenue John world by
which we mean that the second eigen
values is essentially matching up to a
little o terms along bopanna bound and
and I'm putting this here because it's
going to be a little relevance later on
and in 2010 and with an implied we
confirm to the West conjecture so indeed
if you take a random d regular graph
it's going to have this sharp transition
okay this is for simple on the walk and
what I mean by NB this is non
backtracking random walk this is an
important element in this talk so this
is nothing but the their mouths of
change on directed edges of your graph
where you move from X Y to a randomly
chosen Z that is not X form every
directed edge you just kind of continue
to the next directed edge but you are
not allowed to choose Y X and what we
showed here was that actually if you do
that then your convergence is is faster
by a factor of a D over D minus two okay
so am now what what I right here fast as
possible is also going to be a recurring
theme why is this fast as possible let's
look at the non backtracking random walk
the degree so the number of edges you
can move to at every step is b minus 1
because we precluded one so so our
covering tree I mean we grow the balls
of vertices that we see grows at this
rate so if we look at 1 minus epsilon
log D minus 1 over n we see n to the 1
minus epsilon vertices and certainly
will not mixed this is a trivia
and the nice thing about this is that
non backtracking random walk is
essentially mixed once you pass that
point and the same the same thing
applies to simple random walk if you
think about this just the fluctuation if
you walk even if you were just never
repeating visitors that you've already
seen and this is like a complete Street
the fluctuations of going up and down
the tree means that you go down with
with probability d minus 1 over d and up
with probability 1 over B so your speed
is d minus 2 over B and you need the
reciprocal of that to actually make it
to the bottom of this tree so even if
this was a complete a completely ideal
situation will you just sing over this
all the time you cannot beat this bunk
and the simple random walk achieves it
so this is the back in 2010 and we also
had explicit constructions of expanders
that had cut off and once the didn't
have cut off but they were really free
like it so far far from being transitive
we wanted the ability to somehow
manipulate what's going to happen to the
walk so essentially built the tree and
put an expander when its leaves
something like that that's essentially
what we did ok and in Cheyenne in 2015 I
think in the context of some way of was
another paper that we were working on
when you Val give a talk asked whether
it can it can be the case that from
illusion grass will always have cuddles
entity is not trying to seize but just
the fact that the aroma Newton should
should give such a strong constraint on
the geometry that maybe you should have
cut off you for this no no the proof is
elementary and and one of the things
that at least that I want to I want I
was hoping to stress is that the way to
prove something like this is essentially
you want to save it that if you look at
you just count the number of paths that
emanate from X
to essentially two to almost all the
other points that you have the right
number which means that your mass kind
of spreads evenly it's essentially like
walking on a tree which and in
calculations of that form I'll doable on
in the random case because you can kind
of expose the random graph as you go
along and things always fit nicely just
want one I think they wanted to say in
response to the one question the nice
thing is and that's why i put swede mods
result here is that here we looked at
the randomness of the graph in order to
count past seligman how you'll use the
path the control over non backtracking
ray walks in order to control the second
eigenvalue and so there is this very
close relation between the two and this
is also what I'm going to get back to
that a little later that's also what led
us to to reexamine from illusion grass
in this context and somehow things that
that that if you know that it's from
illusion then you should have enough
power to control path links what was the
question Michael was another girl feels
good because before that nothing I kept
so when I saw when I gave read more
colloquial ma in tel aviv university
also in Hebrew University in a couple of
years ago I asked specifically it is the
cutoff on LTS okay so this is simple
random walk and this kind of look like
it's rob this is this is what it should
look like we have a blue curve in a in a
red curve this is L 1 and this is l2 and
I'd like to point out that there is a
gap between them thank for simple random
walk
when you measure the l2 distance of your
vector to the stationary
no no no no does not G this is this is
this is 40 fo LPS looks fierce one
little piece this is a row and row is
there is two sqrt d minus 1/8 okay good
question okay so these are this is a
simulation and this is what's actually
going to happen this is actually
answering Michaels question even though
I didn't get to it yet so this this is
the result with you Val form 2016 we
show that if you have a la mano jaan
graph then you have cut off including on
LPS doesn't have to be transitive the
simple random walk essentially mimics
the result of the random graph okay same
location exactly we have it for LP full
of great question wait with in just a
second I'll just say something very
quickly you don't really need the full
power of being are managed and it can be
weekly la mano jaan and you get the same
thing the little always going to absorb
the little o weekly ramen noodle and you
can also allow some sub polynomial
number of eigen values to be I don't
know to fill the D or anything that is
less than D minus epsilon you should you
should they should be all uniform it
should be an expander should be bounded
away from thee but a sub polynomial
number can be way above the weekly
Ramanujan bound and that should be with
the Illuminati if you know that then the
proof works right so close with your no
preference it's not if it's bipartite
then in the first step you just you you
modify the first step to be lazy with
probability a half and then it's fine so
doesn't say it applies both case you
just want to eliminate it periodically
so I won't have to say what you just
have
ok so the LP so in this slide you the
message was that if you are doing a
simple random walk on the revolution
graph it's as fast as it can be because
this is the delay of going up and down
the tree you can't afford that and this
is essentially your radius of covering
the vertices so this is as fast as you
can go and the same price for any repeat
this is the definition of a or better p
distance it's a relative density with
respect to PI and you take sum over X PT
XY divided by PI Y minus y to the power
of P times Phi of why this is this is
this notation so if you measure
convergence according to help instead of
l1 you have the same results for any p
louder than 10 minuten graph i'll have
the fastest LT mixing layout of wayne
and so there is LP cut-offs and it's in
the best possible location and this is
these are the constants okay I think
topically yeah so this is what it looks
like at one and two two two two zero and
infinity ok but i but i won't discuss a
LP anymore I want to draw your attention
to through the grass distances so here's
the quality remember that I said that
you can extract a lot of information
from the fact that that l1 is synonymous
with total variation up to a photo of
tools what a source of variation tell us
it tells us that if we mix so past time
log d minus 1 or a 0 vain ok so this is
actually a quality of of of
understanding the non backtracking
random walk but but but in any case
suppose that you know that that the non
backtracking random walks it just goes
straight mixes it at this time log D
minus 1 over that means in particular
that you also see all the vertices by
that point up to a negligible affection
so in particular your distance of any
point because we started from the worst
case 12 almost every other point should
be the right one which is what the
says and this was independently shown by
by NASA using a different method you're
using chebyshev polynomials and also i'd
like to point out the fact that you that
the average distance of any two points
is one time log base B minus one event
means that they are missile is at most
two times that okay this is easy because
it takes two thousand two thousand
intersect okay so when so this bound is
essentially the best known bound today
the best known upper bound on Ramanujan
graphs it matches the bound in this
paper again using chebyshev polynomials
of the other time they think and a
bitter i think conjectures it to be
fulfilled but even getting a two-
subside for LPS even getting a 2 minus
epsilon would be dramatic okay so um
[Music]
written program good but I call it their
typical distance to do yes okay and
he'll here's a here's one where well it
looks like already you are using more
information on the graph than the
previous slide show so you can I'm
allowing you to look at a directed edge
so not just to start for my vertex but
to start from a vertex and go in a
specific direction and in these graphs
going in one specific direction is
really can be deadly because the girls
is huge in order to turn around you can
you need to spend a constant times log
in and so even if you point out in a
specific direction and you want to get
to another edge in a specific direction
the distance is still the same okay and
specifically for LPS for instance you
can find simple cycles of length exactly
to log D minus 1 event between any two
points which means is it so it implies
this for one of the size of its most 1
times 0 minus 1 event okay so you can
these are examples of various things
that you can do once you know that these
works actually mix where they do okay
now the key to our analysis was
analyzing the non backtracking random
walk the one this was featured in
Friedman's paper that i mentioned before
and also his follow-up paper notes
understand list and in shallows recent
whole childhood in a word from 2015 and
so so there they they try to bound so to
control the number of paths in order to
get spectral information we start with
the spectral information and want to
control the length of paths so it's kind
of a convicts now and connecting the
simple random octomom backtracking
random walk is an elementary covering
three argument ok 44 for these graphs so
this is something that you can
asking about later but it's really a
it's Elementary the point I guess is
that already already many years ago when
we try to understand the simple random
walk on LPS guess what is the first
thing that you can do when you have the
graph and the information the hypothesis
is algebraic the first thing to do is
just to calculate what the eigenvalues
actually give and and if you do that you
will see that that the the distance of
the walk two equilibria let's say that
the graph is transiting its vertex
tentative and we're looking at the l2
distance two equilibria then what you
have is essentially let's call it a
lambda I i'll put the tilt to say the
time dividing by the degree so this is
these are the eigenvalues of the
transition turn and I'm summing them
from to all the way to n and I'm raising
them to a power raised to t say it's
time T it will be this so I'm starting
from to as opposed to one because one
corresponds to the trivial eigenvalue 1
the time eliminating that says my
distance from PI I have essentially this
expression now this expression if you
look at the LPS graph a linear number of
a of eigenvalues is going to be really
close to the two loops d minus 12
dialogue open about this is a day the
Naga has to pay so this gives the
quantitative version of how many and
cell has cell has a and yeah so yeah so
it's a couple of two but still has a
degree in a in a paper I think it's yeah
it's listen we also write sale but then
like okay anyway so Cylon n eigen values
are going to be close to the edge and so
if you take it doesn't really matter so
you have some epsilon n eigen value
times the give you essentially two would
be minus one divided by V to the power
of two people and you want this big
expression to be small so so what do you
take this guy we call the troll it's
conveniently located here so you need
your row okay too
b 1 hat yo you all to kill the end so
your tea should be one half log base 1
overall of in and that's what that slide
show you now what do you have the lower
bound you have the usual bound that i
just showed the one where we would kind
of exposed vertices as if it's a tree
the l1 bound so the l1 bound is here
this is the over B minus 20 3-1 when and
that's that bound and they differ so
this failed we try this many years ago
the nice thing about the number cracking
random walk is that once you move to the
wrong backtracking random walk then all
of a sudden the l1 and l2 cut off
locations the heels of the each of them
had cut off we couldn't show that this
one had cut off but now we know that its
head cut off here in l2 which has cut
off over there and there's a gap but for
the number tracking random walk
eliminating the cycles cause these two
guys to coincide for the non
backtracking random walk let you pick
this is the number tracking another walk
in l1 and l2 so we could sandwich the l1
is an upper bound by DL to get cut off
here and and extract information on the
simple random walk by the correspondence
between the two walks ok now ok so i
gotta hurry up ok so what is the general
principle the general principle is that
if you look at the universal cafe the
covers will do it for for grass is just
the tree we have a walk that would
bounce up and down we precluded the
possibility of going up by introducing
the long backtracking random oh it can
only do send it never create cycles
doing that cause the l2 and l1 cut off
location to coincide so if we want to
extend this to higher dimensions here is
what we think is going is this is what
one could conjecture if you take any
random walk operator and look at
in the covering in the analog of the of
the covering to Universal cover which is
now this complicated objects that Alex
was supposed to explain to you okay this
is the building but this is just the
generalization that all instead of lines
of the world there are a plane that has
pilings on them going like this in every
in every direction essentially so you
look upstairs and there is this analog
of the universal kappa and you look at
then a random walk or projector film and
it's supposed to be the case that if you
do not introduce cycles or whatever the
analog of this this is a computer torial
condition here that you did not seem to
do say cycles here under the right
condition that I mark is see here for
cycles it should be the case that if you
have is an illusion complex then that
operator its corresponding random walk
should have cut off so we look upstairs
we look at the behavior of the operator
and we can tell you that this operator
is valid and if you have a 10-10 complex
like here you have the Ramanujan grass
then then then not only will you have
cut off but l1 and l2 will coincide and
so on it would be the fastest possible
and all good things are going to be
guaranteed to you ok and ok and and with
all in Alex we we proved the version of
this principle the actual generalization
that we had is that if you are walking
on this on this building and you have an
operator we want it to be the case that
there's a single you look at the diagram
corresponds with operator like all the
past the ticket it induces and you want
us to be it a unique path or none
between any two vertices so it form
every X either you can never get Y or
you can get why exactly in one way and
the same thing happened here this is
just a complicated way of saying it here
you just always go down with just the
tree here there may be forward kind of
directed forwards but but this is a
combinatorial condition and the main
result this is ok this is a what I'm not
going to this is the definition of a
ramanuja
complex you can glance at it for let's
say five seconds one two three four five
I think that in Alex's doctor was only
Hickey instead of a fever holy but other
than that it was roughly in his talk in
one of the opening slide okay and the
result okay with Alex and all week is
that if you take an operator and you
look and you look at this operator on
the analog of the universal color of the
tree that covers your your finite
Ramanujan complex if this called this
this operator you want it to be nice
with the behavior you want it to to be
equivariant so we want you wanted to
behave nicely with respect to the group
that you're acting one okay so this is
kind of a is this is an obvious
condition if its collision flee this is
what I show that they emphasize if it
satisfies the combinatorial condition up
still that's the only thing that that is
required for you to say that if X is
anyone illusion complex so X is the
building mode gamma is any l'évolution
compact then you have cut off and you
have the distances are guarantee the
typical distances exactly as you had
before so we have an analog okay and yes
yeah it's done of them on deck tracking
and here are some examples so we also
have a sufficient necessary condition in
order to actually verify this
combinatorial condition but then but I
gave a couple of I given gave a couple
of examples you will you move form a
triangle to another triangle such depth
to a random kind of directed triangle
such that there is no triangle that that
joins XYZ so so in this case it's a form
a directed edge to a directed edge here
is form a triangle to a triangle will
the overlap and you can read the results
like cut off location which and also
tells you typical
distances and in triangles like that
without disjoint but overlapping just
over 60 or ones that are kind of tightly
packed ok and these these specific
operators were already studied in the
context of the Vita function on illusion
complexes and we can also as a
by-product confirmed what what's called
the Riemann hypothesis so busy to
function but that's beside the point in
the last minute and just want to say
something about about the proof the
original argument in the paper with eval
has essentially two ingredients in the
proof one the main one was the fact that
goes back to Hashimoto using gamma zeta
function that says that the eigenvalues
of the non backtracking random walk of
this operator all we're back to
expanders on all the Ramanujan graph or
line up on the ball of radius square
would be minus one it's in the complex
plane this operator is not normal
anymore but you can still look at the
module of the eigenvalues and all of
them will line up here except for the
trivial one okay so what does it mean
that they line up at the ball of radius
would be minus 1 suppose that we go back
to this exact formula okay this one and
we are ignoring the fact that this is
not a normal operator and that's
actually the eigenfunctions will also
kick in let's ignore that and let's
suppose that this is diagonalizable the
node i agonised or exactly like that
then i replace my lambda till i replace
it by you know what the modulo so it
needs to be like this in the complex
plane the module will just be both d
minus 1 what is my degree that might
degrees d minus 1 so i have 1 over root
d minus 1 to the power of 2t okay which
is just d minus 1 to the minus T which
files an N
so my cutoff is that log base B minus
one event so it's trivial the problem is
that this matrix is not normal and with
you borrow we showed that it's unitarily
similar to a block diagonal matrix with
blocks of sight so it was like this and
we calculated it but you know if it's
just two by two so it's almost normal
and the effect of these little blocks
didn't really amount to much that's how
the proof worked in that paper and what
we do is always and alex is generalize
this to higher dimension this is the
last slide and now there's a non-trivial
to non-trivial step one is to show that
you have a good spectral bound so the
the analog of this ashy mother you want
to say that that you're you're that what
you have is what only referred to
yesterday is that a managed and I
digraph you want to say that the degrees
are essentially square root that the
spectrum is essentially inside the ball
of radius square roots the out the green
and the second is showing that it's
blocked that that that if you owe
operator is good then then it you can
find the unit then it's unitarily
similar to a matrix that block diagonal
with bounded size blocks and bounded
entries and and with this is the the
essence of the new work this is just an
example for the author for one of the
operators that we showed in the previous
a slight that it thank you very much
any more questions as I said it maybe I
trust this morning if you will show
stampeded you actually need a malicious
photos for ok yes ok so so there's a
question of a of defining a what
elements and complexes I mentioned in
the last slide that we okay here he
there were two parts like a spectacle
and an algebraic great in order to say
that that the spectrum is is is the
right one you need to somehow your input
is just that that the operator on the
building's is nicely behaved
combinatorially and now you want to save
it on any finite quotient if gamma is a
compact lattice and so on saturday and
in the end b-mode gamma is ramanuja you
need to say that the spectrum of the
operator on this fine i graph is is it's
fine and for that you need to use the
full power of what it means for what it
means to be gamma Neutron and this is a
this goes back to the slide that i
fast-forwarded they said that if that
relates the representations that you
have downstairs to the presentations
that you say that you have upsells and
it says that they are contained they are
weakly contained in the l to the in l2 +
850 and then you somehow needs to also
do some extra work in order to eliminate
this epsilon because we
ah that's what you're asking about
weekly Ramanujan as opposed to an
illusion no I'll explore MIT what Alex
form is he was trying to make a point
that in some of the other works you you
could replace the drama Newton complex
by a high-dimensional expander with
certain other properties that are
powerful but not but they do not utilize
the full power of being de- jah I think
that's what you would say and in this
work we need it for the pool for the
poof no it's probably too and make sure
that you can announce a class yeah yeah
yeah yeah they're young so as always
said so is it if it's working at aa-
John then it will also work the entire
Assembly's an example for justice to
Spelman they notice of its not correct i
say okay it's correctly adventure there
ought to be such an example it's yeah
but but if let's say that that all of
them are two plus a Cylon 12 plus a
trial on time now we want to say that
you can it ought to be such a counter
example but it's not but nothing is
published just conjecture they want this
back to this stuff in cognitive crystal
something you personally know can I get
two children now the properties of jobs
there's a version of public subjectivity
but the simple rule single month of
katie kox multiplicity of eigenvalues of
second 19 by 565 the second eigenvalue
messages back hours to show that when
you're close to uniform somewhat slow
for mobilizing the next combinatorics
cases users for a blanket per se but
what we are doing is a plus people be
the Jerry things that anyway yourself
taking one step of a random walk I mean
you're close to uniform you can learn
much faster than you convert before but
when if you are in close not exactly so
tamiya so it's Kate could you bring for
a birthday or just whatever that your
uniform on you control this residual
then you need you to be a power of the
side of the graph like a sensitive if
you will enter the point 9 and you have
this multiplicity or tablet subjectivity
in one set yer you now in your case you
don't care about such things and your
poor not as much as the register but do
you care about the genetic or honest it
also packing the moving going to point I
want to say this yeah I want to say that
1.01 event you move to yeah you're close
to your epsilon for your facility on
epsilon and purposes you want to be
saluted of 1-10 and there's only if you
have this condition is the the same
therapist will give you [ __ ] know
helping out there is a bar by people and
used to be a little careful because we
were so busy suggesting something I oh
yeah no no it a you know this is our was
randomness which books will run for the
physics two people sleep tight it's the
largest bounded you know you think
mainly about books i presently people
people to see what it was will happen if
you with a pistol pete three goals in
the Kaniksu avium is what it is is
proper if you have I'm architecture
dragon Valley awesome power your lady
sometimes it doesn't emphasize on you
know a location where a longer
conditions of subjectivity as reason
and then your point nine is there is
there according to Israel is there some
alpha that is associated with their with
this point I'm always indicate that if
you enter the Delta for any Delta if I
fix the Delta and now let n go to
infinity if I met n to the death then in
a few steps i'll get to ok that's what
that's what we need is the definition of
capital castle to be even warmer than
want of the low one maybe between point
10 9 yeah you just need a concert um yes
for the long bones cracking random walk
on the random graphs case it's all the
one the window is exactly like that one
may ask what is the number of go back to
your side yeah continue
so you may as what is the number of
points between with interns more than
alpha funny blogs they're halfway
between one and two we know it's zero
komatsu you know it's almost all around
one subset cycle but what's going on in
DC so that's why our target
exponentially decaying yeah I thought
though I think I've been debating this
yes but one month in which I was added
he considers trooper all from original
draft computing three Doors not too
healthy a common agenda then the 800
will incorporate between a one and the
point for our three so you just need to
to form our street and that short order
that you living a functional right you
can only help I think ought to be the
number it so it doesn't decay just like
just like this it will decay like this d
minus one that should be the exponent of
your decay the exponent of the decay
past one of the number of points you
should continue to look like this so
this is the way that you decay after one
maybe we're not talking about the same
thing diameter is different for typical
distances it like some exceptional
points points related to your hold yeah
okay yeah that's it that is yeah that is
different maybe we'll cut now there is
the question to leave it for later
and let me just remind you that maybe we
should thank a health
[Applause]